daily wire has this report fast food
restaurant chain Chick-fil-A received
backlash on social media as
conservatives learned that the firm's
corporate office advances a number of
diversity initiatives a revelation which
came as Brands such as Bud Light and
Target face criticism for embracing woke
ideology social media users noted that
Chick-fil-A which is a long-standing
reputation as a firm run on the basis of
conservative and Christian principles
hired Eric Reynolds as vice president of
diversity equity and inclusion
Chick-fil-A prominently features a
number of diversity programs meant only
for females and members of racial
minorities Beyond collaborations with
various National diverse professional
development organizations such as the
women's Food Service forums the national
black MBA Association and the
association of Latino Professionals of
America the company also seeks to
develop quote mentorship development and
partnership opportunities for
minority-owned businesses to
strategically engage with their supply
chain Chick-fil-A additionally includes
sexual orientation gender identity and
gender expression in its employment
non-discrimination statement alongside
race sex religion and Veteran status
first of all as others have pointed out
this is no surprise from Chick-fil-A